[Music]
now I'm skirts hello there reach neck
nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey
or I'm John Humphrey wait John I'm John
Bailey Bailey the epic mother-effing
voice guy is here with us today to watch
how spider-man far from home should have
ended he does not remember if he worked
on this room I don't think so we've done
some busy reactions or like that's gotta
be it is John Bailey he's not in this
one so it's it's pure reaction yes you
never know no I anticipate I don't know
I don't remember you don't get access
like the full scripts or anything right
no I think they actually sent me the
full thing what they're not tight on
secrecy water mark your name I've heard
Marvel has their films like separated on
separate hard drives with separate keys
like the presidential nuclear weapons
yeah I don't think I would've in is
quite that's true Wow they let me down
all right let's watch this okay finally
done equipping my glasses with access to
all my state-of-the-art technology for
Peter in case I gotta how to just write
some vague instructions to turn them on
and give them a Nick Fury will hopefully
just hand them to Peter one how about
you don't give military-grade death
drone controlling eighties glasses to an
easily influenced hormonal teenager just
because he has a foxy and I'm dang
you're right
[Laughter]
[Music]
like dead thoughts oh I see what they
did there well done on that inch on that
title that's that's awesome title
q guys already my foe mighty heroes
those who've lived away were saved
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
for you
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I was like wouldn't you change the
controls just kind of continue to
manipulate the masses because I'm a
master illusionist you ripoff syndrome
boy why don't you take a seat next to
the Mandarin over there I'm not copying
you if anything you copied me wish you
guys are just jealous because everyone
finds me most attractive waiting for
that Sony jammers right
[Music]
no better boys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's that's brilliant how they have
all Batman bit because we were all
expecting if you watch through even
though they subvert it though you're
like okay what they're gonna still
acknowledge the whole because
right and then all right I guess they're
just not gonna point that out oh you
know the comments what is NaN stuff yeah
because it says because I'm gonna adult
I'm like okay but there's gonna be some
joke following up that he didn't say it
I guess not and then they have that vid
playing on the scroll that's brilliant
routing that I'd like the writing that's
a lorry running like they're really good
writers I'm on a first-name basis with
them to double tap I mean one of my
favorite things about what would dnt do
John oh my favorite things about their
work is while their commentary and the
jokes are always hilarious consistently
they usually bring up points I just
never thought about and so much would
eat it they had scenes here that is so
true like with the Edith at the bar when
he's talking with Mysterio and Howie
this should have been able to identify
them right away I don't remember the
scene that well to the public with the
glasses on I remember or the fact that
Mysterio would have put some way to
block Peter from getting yeah it was
convenient like hey Edith the back we're
used to render control yeah that's true
but even in this ending post-credit
scenes he could have probably relied on
eeeh to somehow this transmission I mean
you could have put those into costumes
somehow my good days to prepare maybe
it's one of those things were once they
had it in the script so much of a
solution to every problem or maybe
there's they sometimes do alternate
scenes or other things that they didn't
you know for a patreon or in that
support so maybe there's more stuff that
we don't know about that they did do
they got cut for Sony's patron support
us on patreon and why'd he give the
glasses to rody bright or some kind of I
mean I guess he gave rodia's suit but
yeah it seems like they would have just
been left and better they like best
friends for like ever
well now he's got bitter you know yes a
teenage boy that is you know not son I
think maybe because this was written at
a certain point they said San Diego
Comic Cons when they made submissions
yeah well this has written by the fans
you know technically they had nothing to
do no more that Gordon's got to take
long enough that they can't probably
just drop a joke in last minute yeah
yeah because they didn't do any Sony or
MCU jokes and I think we were all
expecting yeah we were expecting a lot
because the only kind of joking they're
not they reference the MC hue like a
million Oh what even though I want them
to partner back up when they showed the
footage of Andrew Garfield and Tobey
Maguire I've been wanting to see like
old man Peter with totally wire I wanted
to see that version and it made me go
you know the possibility if a crossover
now with the three of that right would
be cool it's likely to happen if they
are all just within Sony a live action
spider versus three taking like swagger
[ __ ] Doctor Who when they put three
doctors in one episode that's not like a
true universe that's just a crossover I
think you got a gaff I it with the ones
that work well in live-action that's I
just wanted Ross over the whole thing
with the hologram to see I like when
they're making fun of a amazing
spider-man 2 what he's a firefighter any
way shape or form yeah they would have
just you know vapor in the hologram
element was kind of confusing because I
think that's what I was selling me on
that there might be real when I was
watching the movie I was like Masseria
is definitely a bad guy but maybe these
elementals are actually yeah that was
thinking the same thing because they're
based on Marvel characters right yeah
but then also when they're touching them
they seem like they're being touched man
I feel like if i rewatch that fellow but
who's been looking for every little well
he doubled me he double the damage guys
yeah yes and nobody could hear the
machine guns from the drones when every
time there was an explosion about other
heroes like me even forget about
spider-man Oh buddy he's in New York
where's daredevil where's Punisher
there's some guys around I can help out
there are no European superheroes they
only live in New York Chicago and LA I'm
curious to know though how much of this
was just fan ideas and how much they
rewrote into their own version or they
took an idea that the fan came up
and animate it in a way where it made it
even better I'm pretty sure there's
gonna be a fan submitting of a questions
for them to take down this video because
they're like you
you changed my jokes you said I wrote
this but I did not raise my property
yeah you should get a fan commentary
version of this and I remember signing
anything there's no legal contract you
know what I came up with his djoko's I
wrote this story down the toilet paper
in my bed to get the toilet paper but I
gotta bring up the secret identity thing
he does tell his secret identity he's
like James Bond bring his point
yeah everyone important to him no it's
the exact office any people not afford
cuz I haven't talked to you guys since I
watched that movie like that part I was
so happy about because I don't know if
you remember the original comics
daredevil got busted first and he's like
I always thought it would be spider-man
and in the movies right you know he's
like I always just assumed it would be
spider-man that was like everybody finds
out who he is but instead it's daredevil
the fact that they did that was
spider-man to say and I'm like that's
freaking awesome because that's the
first thing I thought what that
commentary to with Batman about like
does everybody that joke even though it
subverts the other joke you're expecting
I do that was like an actual character
beat where he's like I'm gonna die I can
deal with this you're in way over your
head if you have a good head on your
shoulders you can't have the full scope
of life to be operate I mean but I loved
this past week isn't Kevin Feige was
saying I'm glad we made I'm feeling
grateful for spider-man we made the
movies we wanted to make I'm like you
made the movies you want her to make by
leaving spider-man on this like crazy
cliffhanger drop so many leads to the
MCU and then they're like sorry so
what's gonna happen next vitamins like
okay guys Avengers company's dead lion
others say like ah he's across yeah 2d
well they probably wanted to say his
name is Billy welcome he right now yeah
where's the kid yeah something like that
something well guys this was hilarious
if you haven't subscribed to how it
should have been did you should do that
right away thank you so much for being
here this technically I was in there
because they showed a picture of Ant Man
like one for one second
you get like I did the voice of a rely
on anybody I don't get residuals for it
they just show my characters you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell as well but
I'd like to give a page from the day
shadow we're gonna use John Bailey's
help here for someone don't mess this up
so we've got to give a page for the day
shout out to a person let's go with
Daniel Gallagher
oooh Gallagher yeah being shouted out on
patreon or on YouTube thanks for your
support
alright now can you can you do that
again but with like a a Ryan Reynolds
voice the Ryan Reynolds voice well thank
you Gallagher I really enjoy your comedy
I hope you continue smashing watermelons
forever it seems very enjoyable
I'll bring extra garbage bags yeah ask
you later you gotta get you to other
Lord of smuggles I'm kidding neither
mine we did it your shoutouts complete
I'm just gonna call John Bailey unlock
of the he I keep talking about their
genitals because I don't know what
that's all about it is so many baby
names
[Laughter]
[Music]